بعد أكثر من مائة ساعة من أسوأ
زلزال منذ ما يقرب من مائة عام وما
زالت هناك أضواء لن تنطفئ
لتذكير بأن هذا حدث أثناء نوم الجميع
وهذا الفجر الجديد مرحبًا به ، لذا
لا توجد طريقة أفضل لإظهار أنك على قيد الحياة من
هذه الابتسامة.
الحشود في كل موقع أكبر صوتًا في
النجاح الآن عدد الذين يعيشون مدفونين
هو أصغر ،
تم سحب زوج تيمودو
قبل لحظات من ذلك ،
ليس عليهم الذهاب بعيدًا لتذكيرهم
بعدد عمليات البحث التي تنتهي
كل لحظة من Hope هي الأكثر حدة هنا
حيث الجيش  تشكل المروحيات وسيارات
الإسعاف تيارًا ينقل
الجرحى إلى المستشفيات في المدن التركية الأخرى
لأن الكثير من الفتيات هنا مشلولة تبلغ من
العمر ثلاث سنوات وهي تدرك
أختها البالغة من العمر شهرين ، كما
أنه من غير الواضح ما إذا كانوا يعرفون مكان
والدتهم التي لا يعرفها أحد هنا  يتم
الاندفاع إلى المسنين أيضًا ولكنهم أيضًا
صغيرون جدًا لدرجة أنهم يتشاركون نقالة
ويجب حملهم على متن الطائرة
وهم يطيرون أيضًا دون والديهم
15 مريضًا في المجموع هذا الصباح
تذكر على الرغم من أن هذه هي الطريقة التي تنتهي بها معظم القصص
هنا
مقابر مستعجلة في  تم حفر المقبرة باليد والورق
المقوى
حتى هذه رفاهية نسبية في وقت
لا يوجد فيه
أسرتان من أربعة لقوا حتفهم في
نفس المبنى
[موسيقى]
عبر هذه المدينة على الرغم من أن مهمة
دفن العديد من الأشخاص العاجلين أيضًا
في موقع Rebel قد بدأ بحث آخر
لهذا المقيم  يشرح من الداخل
[الموسيقى] ،
الأمل الآن هو لأم شقيق Yesham
وأبها
ممرضة كانت هنا منذ يوم الثلاثاء ، لقد كنت
أعاني منذ خمسة أيام ، لقد
فقد الجميع الأمل الآن
وأرسلوا لي التعازي
وأخبرني المسؤولون أنهم سيجدون فقط
الجثة والآن خرج شخصان على
قيد الحياة ،
نحتاج إلى عمال إنقاذ محترفين ،
استقال فريق الإطفاء علينا ، وجدنا هذين الاثنين
للتو مع عمال البناء ، لقد
أحضرت ثلاثة أكياس للجثث ، ربما أحتاجهم
ومقابر في الغسق ،
وبوصة الحفر بعناية للأمام دون وقت
الحد من أو ضمان العثور على أي شيء
وسط المدينة غارق في الغبار
والمعرفة الثقيلة بأنه كلما طالت مدة
صبرهم وكفاحهم ، قل احتمال حصولهم على
مكافآت نيك بيتون والش CNN
و Takia تركيا